now that we took a little bit of a break
hey some good texas brisket thank you
for that by the way all right i'm over
quite welcome let me ask the ridiculous
question
at the core of uh the idea of bitcoin is
this guy or this entity named satoshi
nakamoto
so the ridiculous question is who is
satoshi nakamoto
and first of all is it you it's not me
i wish and is this an interesting
question
or is it just something about our human
nature that wants to that always
uh tends towards mystery well as we've
touched on
a bit today you know mythology
in my opinion is something that is
intrinsic to how we see the world
in a lot of ways like it's how it's kind
of the structure
by which we build these useful fictions
and so in that way you could just say
that satoshi is
the godhead of bitcoin effectively and
i think a compelling argument can be
made that his disappearance is what
really solidifies bitcoin's
decentralization
because if there were one individual to
personally
vilify or denigrate or attack
um you know to disparage or question the
motives of
um you know if he's out on the hollywood
hills partying
everyone knows he's got a million
bitcoin you know it would just
kind of tarnish the entire project a lot
of way but the fact that
on that theme something for nothing this
guy actually gave humanity something for
nothing
and it appears that he
didn't profit in any way he she or they
um actually heard recently that he
identified as a he
in some of his communications so it
sounds like it is a he
um see like
his communication is being like studied
like almost like
exactly as if he is a religious uh
that's right
like a prophet yeah i mean it's
fascinating to imagine that
he's still alive and
living in this world and it's even more
fascinating to imagine that he's perhaps
participating in the bitcoin community
because i mean that's that takes a
special human being to
out of principle do that to do uh to to
remain anonymous
that's very much the george washington i
always wonder like how many people are
like
that there's a cliche that like absolute
power corrupts absolutely
like power corrupts but it seems like
the progress
of humanity depends on the people whom
power doesn't corrupt
[Music]
that's interesting and it's enough to
have just a small selection of those
and even if most of us are too weak
we give in to power if given the chance
all it takes is a few that's i've never
thought of it like that but
marcus released immediately came to mind
yeah you know the guy that
he had the keys to the kingdom and he
apparently adhered to the stoic virtues
until the end
but yeah i agree with satoshi the other
thing that's interesting is
he would be by far the most
wealthy person in the world on a liquid
asset basis
because he has a million bitcoin which
is 60
billion liquid net worth at current
prices so if he is still alive and just
operating in the world
he is daily and moment to moment
resisting
massive incentives to go
and just be the richest guy in the world
he's the ultimate handler yeah yeah
i mean so it's i mean it's turning down
not just financial
success but also fame i mean fame is
another drug
it's a kind of power but it's in itself
is also a drug especially in this modern
society
in this attention and he would have both
he would have both
it's fun to imagine who who it could be
it's fascinating if it's
somebody like you or somebody like elon
or somebody like that
that's fascinating to think about i
think elon would be hilarious
if you came out and he was satoshi like
hey guys i know
i'm already the richest guy in the world
but i gotta go ahead and double my lead
here
you